[Music]
eileen is with us in connecticut hey
arlene how are you
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve i am
i'm a first time caller but i listened
to you for a long time well thank you
how can we help
i am going to turn 59 and a half
and i was thinking of paying off my
mortgage with my tsp something
cool
how much is your mortgage um
um 82 000 how much in the tsp
730
thousand great do it
do it okay yep so you got to make it on
600 000 with no debt
life's rough right and i have another
roth outside the psp too
you killed it girl you're a millionaire
what's the house worth
320. i told you you're a millionaire
wow you're so proud of you hear that
you ever thought about it i mean you add
up what you what you own minus what you
owe and if it's one million or greater
you're a millionaire
yeah yeah i thought about it yeah hard
to believe it took a while but yeah okay
well i mean this is what you've been
doing what'd you do for a living right
post office what'd you do at the post
office
just a clerk inside you know
just a clerk millionaire
right i started at what thirty thousand
and this is the high point sixty nine
thousand but i've been there thirty five
years
you're single
yeah well i'm divorced yes there was a
divorce in the middle there how long you
been divorced in one
oh 15 years okay
and one son he's 22. yeah
yeah so you can do it hey um i want you
to go look in the mirror because you're
pretty impressive woman
oh
okay
your dad got a millionaire as a post
office clerk shut up this is this is
amazing it's freaking amazing
yeah you did good
you did good i'm kind of
kind of a nerd yeah
well you've been the tortoise so long
you forgot it was impressive
yep you're steady
you're predictable yes
right and all those all those nights you
wondered if you were gonna make it when
you were going through this divorce
right now they all paid off
yeah you made it a little nerve-wracking
you made it you made it you did it
that's great to hear that i mean i mean
you're 69 years old you get 600 700
thousand dollars with a paid for house
after this conversation 59.
well what i say 60 years old 59 60 yeah
i mean yeah yeah close enough i mean
maybe 59 and a half to do this but yeah
ding ding
thank you
yeah what do you tell people that their
secret to being a millionaire is
ah you just gotta be disciplined and
just you know every week it just
automatically goes in
and
that's it what kind of uh which funds
did you use in the tsp
the c yeah the cs9 mostly see you though
yeah so you've been following our stuff
for a long time
a long time yeah how long am i
oh
15 years or more yeah wow you're a baby
steps millionaire we need to somehow
bottle that call
and
for the the group in america that's out
there saying you can't make it in
america today
we need to remind you that a postal
clerk just called here yeah
making 35 to 69 000 through her working
lifetime and became a millionaire by 59.
we need to remind you people the little
man can't get ahead
the rich just keep getting richer and
the poor keep getting poorer wealth
inequality is not fair let me tell you
what the fair is the fair is where the
tilt-a-whirl is and the cotton candy is
that's what fair is
what's fair is that woman put money into
her tsp and didn't go out to eat while
your butt was down there stuffing tacos
and you and then you want to go well you
can't share let me tell you what's not
fair it's not fair that you want some of
her money and you just let this
president raise taxes on her
tax bill just went through that raised
taxes on her
that's not fair
oh now you're getting me excited i mean
really and so this is this crap man
and this idea that you know this country
is so broken that people can't get ahead
that sweet little lady there that's true
just work steady worked hard work
discipline worked consistently she had a
life
she didn't live in a cave and collect
lint and only come out on triple coupon
thursday but she was diligent she was
intentional and she became a millionaire
by 59
and then you call me up and tell me it
can't happen in america again kiss my
butt
it can too it absolutely can i talk to
these people every day
every day everywhere i go and i can't
stand it when you hope steelers out
there in the name of your leftist agenda
keep telling people that this place is
so broken that you can't win hey we got
our problems but we're the still the
best shot you got if you're the little
man in the entire world
america's still the best shot for the
little man in the entire world that's a
statistical fact you morons this is the
ramsay show